Hey youtubers it’s Charlie.
Welcome back to my season 4 countdown.
Today we’re going to talk about some movies.
Recently George RR Martin revealed that Game
of Thrones movies are probably going to happen
once the series is over.
Everyone involved kind of agrees that they
have at least 7, maybe 8 seasons worth of
material for the tv show.
So we’re talking 2019 before we’d ever
see one.
The movies he talked about mostly had to do
with the expanded material.
You know, prequel series he’s already done
work on like Dunk and Egg, the Blackfyre rebellion,
The Night King, you get the idea.
All the awesome stuff you want to see but
they don’t have the money to do right now.
With any luck, Game of Thrones will become
a much better version of what happened with
the Star Wars universe.
So here’s what we’re going to do.
I’m going to count off my top 5 picks for
stories I think would make for the best movies.
Quick shout out for the countdown.
If you’re finding me for the first time
I’m doing special countdown videos for the
season 4 premiere.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything and
leave me suggestions on videos you want to
see.
My next one will be a Q&A video.
So leave your questions too!
Here we go, Number 5 - The Hedge Knight.
Also known as Dunk and Egg.
Dunk is short for Ser Duncan the Tall and
Egg is the nickname for the future King Aegon
Targaryen the fifth.
The series takes place when Aegon was like
Bran’s age.
He was Ser Duncan’s squire.
All of the Dunk and Egg stuff takes place
about 90 years before the current events on
the show.
Martin already wrote a novella in the Legends
Anthology for this.
It became the first Dunk and Egg story that
was later turned into a comic book at Marvel.
So if you want to read a Game of Thrones comic
book you can do that right now.
It’s an ongoing series.
There are two other novella called Sworn sword
and The Mystery Knight.
A fourth one called The She Wolves of Winterfell
is currently planned for another anthology
this year.
So Martin has already spent a ton of time
developing these characters.
This makes the most sense for a prequel movie
or even tv series.
Plus they can re-use most of the costumes
from the show, just because it happens so
close to current events.
The Dunk and Egg stories also overlap with
The Blackfyre rebellion, the Bloodraven and
the War of the Ninepenny Kings.
So this material could really be the backbone
of a whole new series of movies, not just
one.
As a side note, If you’re bummed that Winds
of Winter is taking so long to get here.
Just read all these anthology stories.
They’re awesome.
Number 4 - The Blackfyre Rebellion.
King Aegon the Fourth, who was the worst king
in the history of Westeros.
Legitimizes all his bastards, and one of them
makes a claim on the Iron Throne.
This becomes the second major civil war after
the Dance of The Dragons.
The primary characters are Daemon Blackfyre,
who started the rebellion, the Bloodraven,
his half-brother and King Daeron the second.
Interesting side note.
One of the other Blackfyre bastards escaped
at the end of all this to the east and formed
the Gold Company, one of the most famous groups
of mercenaries.
The whole thing started because Aegon the
fourth thought his son Daeron was secretly
fathered by his brother.
So he gave his valyrian sword called Blackfyre
to his bastard son Daemon.
Legitimizing him.
People kind of associated this really famous
sword that had been passed down from Aegon
the first, as a visual sign of the succession.
So when you gave the sword to someone, it
was like saying you want them to be king next.
And civil war blew up everywhere.
Remember though, there are a ton of huge characters
involved.
Number 3 - The Bloodraven.
Ser Brynden Rivers.
One of the other legitimized bastards of Aegon
the fourth.
There is so much story that his character
is involved in.
The first and second Blackfyre rebellions.
He was hand of the king for a long time, he
was present during all the Dunk and Egg stories
and he was a magic user.
He primarily practiced Glamouring, which is
changing your features.
But he also became the last greenseer and
may or may not be part of season 4.
Of all the characters in a song of ice and
fire.
He is definitely one of the most interesting.
I don’t want to include too many spoilers,
because a lot of his story spills over into
what’s happening right now.
But feel free to ask me about it in the comments.
Number 2 - The Dance of The Dragons.
The first major Targaryen Civil War.
Martin actually just published this as a novella
in the Dangerous Women anthology.
That’s the short version.
There’s a complete history of the event
he’s writing for a new book after he’s
done with all the Song of Ice and Fire books.
It’s called Fire and Blood and it’s the
complete history of the Targaryen house.
For this movie idea I’m mostly focusing
on the Dance of the Dragons event, but you
get the idea.
You could do a whole new tv series told exclusively
from the Targaryen’s perspective across
the entire history of Westeros.
It’s not that there’s no good ideas, there’s
way too many good ideas.
If you haven’t read the short story, the
Dance is just a civil war that started right
after the death of the king and involved his
son and his daughter from another woman.
And a whole lot of dragons.
The real attraction of this story is that
it becomes a war fought on the backs of dragons.
Mostly distinguished by their color.
One of the big problems of the Targaryen succession
was that they engaged in the kind of sisterwiving
that Jaime and Cersei have been doing.
So when they cheated on each other, they did
it with other Targaryens.
So sometimes you had bastard children born
inside the royal line of succession, making
things super complicated.
and my Number 1 pick Filling in the gaps of
the current story.
Even though the show does an amazing job of
telling the book story.
It still has to leave a lot of things out.
An extra movie is an easy way to fill in those
gaps.
Like telling the full story of Jon Snow’s
mother, Robert’s rebellion, and other things
happening that even George RR Martin hasn’t
paid off yet.
Martin will sometimes drop minor plots, like
the idea that Syrio Forel is really Jaquen
H’Gar. Little things like that.
And most of the time on the show is dedicated
to things happening in Westeros, but you have
the Frozen North beyond the wall and the East.
There are two more books coming and Martin
has said that we will get our first look at
the distant North, called the Lands of Always
winter.
Guess which book that’s coming in.
But, using a movie right after the series
finishes season 8 would be a really easy way
to mop up any loose plots that they didn’t
have the time or money to do during the seasons.
Now it’s your turn though.
If they start making Game of Thrones movies
which story would you want to see.
Something with the current characters, or
a prequel story like Dunk and Egg?
Remember, I’m posting my Q&A video tomorrow.
Be sure to leave all your questions.
Right now click here for all my season 4 countdown
videos and click here to learn about the first
couple of episodes this season.
And winds of winter.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!